welcome back i'm glad you could join me
today the point of a bob ross challenge
is usually to create the most relaxing
beautiful landscape you can however
we've taken that and turned it into a
anxiety inducing competition yeah don't
freak out no one stop freaking out take
you huh
let's get crazy this is our world so we
can do anything
today we are taking on the bob ross
challenge welcome back i'm glad you
could join me today you ready to do a
fantastic little painting if you don't
know about bob ross it's okay i don't
know much about him either all we need
to know is that he creates beautiful
landscape images in about an hour we
about have a finished painting none of
us here are traditional painters our
forte here is using cgi 3d rendering and
today we're going to bring those
strengths to the art of bob ross we're
joined today by matthew collimore
matthew is a cinema 4d magician i feel
like neo about to take the first jump
and everyone's watching it's very
stressful the point of a bob ross
challenge is usually to create the most
relaxing beautiful landscape you can
however we've taken that and turned it
into a anxiety inducing competition
where we're going to have to follow a
bob ross episode in real time and create
a 3d version of whatever the heck he's
trying to paint did you guys know that
bob ross was a
drill sergeant in the air force you're
so ugly you could be a modern art
masterpiece the reason why he has this
personality is that he
said that he never wanted to yell at
another person ever again we don't we
don't make mistakes we have happy
accidents
just like robert ross takes his paints
and puts him on his palette and gets his
canvas nice and prepped with a good
white wash we must prep our assets for
our 3d program
i'm ready all right are you hiding in
there
is this just full of assets right now
hey don't touch my assets
i have some assets up my sleeve
so they're going to show us the final
result for five seconds
we're going to take the damage we're
gonna have to burn it in our mind and
we're going to have to go and get the
assets that we're going to use to make
this image tomorrow all right
i think i got uh something in my sleeve
that's gonna help me out here i think
the the cabin and the fence are gonna be
the big noticeable elements you know i
just went for like the blanket like you
know i got some grass i got some rocks i
got a sunset already loaded up i've been
prepping all my asses for this very
moment every asset i've ever prepped has
led up to this i'm gonna i've got a
style in mind
i'm gonna try to do a very
simple
clean aesthetic so instead of trying to
worry about getting like photo real
trees i'm going to make a very
stylized scene that still resembles the
overall image that bob ross painted
since we're watching this episode in
real time and have to build the
environment as we watch it i need
something with speed bob ross has got a
paint brush and a palette of paint and
that's it he's not going in after he
doesn't make a brush stroke and then go
in and
you know
so i'm going to use unreal engine so you
can make really really nice environments
really fast this is how fast it is i go
i open my foliage pack i open my trees
oh what are we thinking alaskan cedar
i can make trees anywhere i want
epic games bought mega scans which is
the source of like some of the most high
quality
textures and 3d models that are made
from like photo
images
as long as i download about like 200
gigabytes worth of 3d models i'll be
fine
hundreds of gigabytes millions of pixels
our assets are finally here and ready to
go so today we start the challenge
we all have to start with a clean slate
scene correct we gotta start with a
clean scene
no one does if it's an accident it must
be a happy one
no undos
[Music]
i'm very calm right now
i'm so calm i literally had surgery a
week ago on my shoulder which was not
the same as my collarbone different
things so ren's gotta somehow use his
mouse so i have to have my mouse like
over here now as opposed to want to have
it which is over there i can't put my
arm right there all right well here we
go
i got a blank scene file
got a blank file here
let me down bobby ready as i'll ever be
paints
a new day's dawn now
hi welcome back i'm glad you could join
me today and today i have one of my
little friends here that's having lunch
while we're doing this so oh you have a
squirrel oh he's got a baby squirrel
ross is a lover of animals and sometimes
he brings little chipmunks and squirrels
to hang out with him while he paints
come on up to the canvas let me show you
what i've got done today i've done
something a little bit different today
whoa wait he didn't start with a clean
canvas
what is this freaking b-ross starts with
a freaking pre-made
thing let's make a big decision maybe
maybe right up in here we'll put just a
little bit of this color
is that the sun well that's the sun
yeah we got my hdri ready to go looks
like we got some nice sunset it's kind
of interesting that he's starting with
the atmosphere and like we have to kind
of start with like laying stuff out a
little bit to get our cameras figured
out
he's really focusing on that gradient
i am spending way too much time on this
stupid ground oh that's a big sun i'm
going to make my son bigger
oh that's big
look at that i mean
that's like exactly what he has there
it looks perfect
you know what honestly i'm going to just
hit save and build my lighting and watch
this for a bit let's begin putting in
the indication here and there and there
and here
oh what's he doing what's he doing
what you doing bobby oh he's starting
with the trees
i'm still trying to get my sky to appear
oh my cinema's frozen uh-oh here we go
now let's get started
oh hey
brandio ross here and uh courtesy of
today's sponsor vesey shoes well the
guys are doing their cgi bob ross
challenge i thought i would take this
vessy shoe right here which belongs to
my wife and do a little painting on it
for her and in the process tell you guys
a little bit about these shoes why
they're great and why they're the only
pair of shoes that you're ever really
going to need
so let's go ahead and get started okay
all right so uh first thing i'm going to
make a little grassy knoll probably with
a rainbow and now the first thing that's
important to remember a lot of people
talk about how they don't want to get
their shoes dirty right they don't want
to get them wet with vessi that's a
thing of the past they're 100 waterproof
you can walk through snow rain mud sleet
slush and your feet are going to be dry
nothing you step in is a mistake when
you wear bessies um it's all just happy
little accidents it's
starting to come together i need to get
a little bit more saturation in here the
next thing you need to know about
besties is that they're breathable okay
they're made from a flexible and
patented dimetex material which means
that they keep you cool in the summer
and of course warm in the winter fesies
are the best travel shoe out there
whether you're caught in a storm walking
through town or on and off at airports
vessies will meet all of your needs
besties are also very lightweight it
almost feels like you're wearing no
shoes at all almost like a sock a lot of
people compare it to i'm really liking
this blue right now it's really turning
out
and uh one more thing you should know
about vesey's is that they have an
incredibly efficient manufacturing
process fessy manufacturing is 97
percent more efficient than other shoe
brands because they use 99
of the raw materials it's low waste and
better for the environment
[Music]
all right well i think we're pretty much
done here i'm gonna let this dry for a
little bit um and then i'll show it to
my wife i think she's gonna love it and
uh if you guys are interested in getting
25
off your pair of bessie shoes head on
over to
vesey.com
corridor crew and that's exactly what
you'll get that's
coral crew for 25
off your pair of bessie shoes it's your
shoe
what did you do to my shoe
what is do you know what am i what am i
supposed to do with this
anyways
until next time brandi ross signing off
have a great day everybody decide where
you want these little things maybe this
little tree
lives right here oh okay trees are just
there now oh he's got lots of trees i
gotta get way more trees in there he
just he made like a bunch of trees i
thought i just made like one tree
oh you cannot undo mistakes it's just
happy accidents
it was reflex it was an accident wow
they actually programmed in
a thing that keeps you from undoing wait
what seriously like
oh
thank daniel for that my hand by default
sits on control z this is like such a
knife
my trees are way too big
oh [ __ ]
dude my trees are massive um i gotta
mess with the scale of this stuff how do
i do that i need to make my trees
smaller this is where all the little
creatures live little bunny rabbits live
back here he's already okay he's got so
many trees so many trees trees are just
like it makes it look so effortless all
right i am like totally stuck what am i
trying to do i haven't added any trees
yet why is my grass
black this is not good i am confused my
computer is bugging out see we didn't
factor in that uh oil paints don't have
crashes or errors cg geek actually did a
cg bob ross video but he did a lot more
like interpretive he didn't do it to the
exact same time
that uh
that we did here uh if you guys want to
see somebody else's take on it and doing
a blender i'll go check out his channel
yeah cj geek's pretty cool he's a geek
like us
oh look at that look at that
sometimes i like to do little evergreen
trees where you can see parts of the
trunk
those are not pine trees okay those are
different types of trees
i i know that
i thought they were gonna be pine trees
i had a pine tree somewhere but i can't
find it
yeah don't freak out no one stop
freaking out oh no
octane crashed
no
no
gallery starts in my 4d let's see how
much work i lose
tell you what
let's get crazy this is our world so we
can do anything maybe one little happy
bush that lives over right there
you look away and you look back it's a
whole new tree it just popped in i'm i'm
just still trying to make my background
trees i've never used octane scatter
now's a good time to try
i'm helping
oh my god
oh my god
taking a moment to make my trees better
this whole thing's looking oh crazy the
material i use automatically
procedurally makes grass everywhere okay
so i don't even have to place it
let's make a big decision maybe we have
maybe there's a nice grassy area in our
world and it comes
right down
oh the grass is just appearing instantly
i'm still working on the pine trees
i'm also running into uh gpu memory
issues right now because these trees
have so many polygons
it's like i have to optimize my scene
the exact same time that i make it
my octane is so slow i'm changing things
and nothing's happening
there's always problems
is this intense for everyone this is
pretty intense this is extremely intense
i don't know how bob ross maintains his
calm cool demeanor he must be just like
sweating under that blue collared shirt
that he's wearing shoot i'm going to do
it
i want a little house right here this is
my world i don't want to live right in
here oh he's got a house going up
already
i already have a house
cabin
safe
oh my god i've had this asset for a long
time been meaning to use it for
a while
oh my god
it's the exact same cabin
oh my god oh [ __ ] i just put bushes on
the roof
i'm really glad i prepped all these
trees beforehand because this would not
be uh
nearly what it is now
i'm feeling all right actually like i've
gotten to a point i've got that minimum
viable product you know
i'm really just trying to like i notice
how good his lighting is they say robert
kincaid is the master of light the
painter of light i actually think bob
ross
could show
mr kincaid a thing or two
beautiful day here hope it is where
you're at
we'll just sparkle this up
okay this is actually looking pretty
nice
i mean i'm getting i'm kind of getting
to where i was envisioning in my head
but it's like not really working well i
need a lot more time to be able to
really dial in my look here so i'm going
to try something drastic
i need a way to get to that place
shoot i'm about to put him out there and
leave him deserted so let's take some
van dyke brown we just use a fan brush
we're just laying a little brown and
have a little path that comes right out
here
you making a path
oh i'm not going to make a path that's
for sure path's not happening
path's just not happening
the path
this path's happening
maybe there was a fence here at one time
oh what the heck is that
a fence
there's a fence here that goes right
over the hill we don't know where it
goes
oh fences in the distance i was not i
was not ready for that okay but i can
handle that unlike bob ross i can copy
and paste
why won't my fence render
so i hope you've enjoyed this painting
it's
quite interesting oh that's it
oh what hold up he just
breezes right through it so from all of
us here i'd like to wish you happy
painting and god bless my friend
[Music]
god damn it this is it
guys is what we train for
[Music]
all right i i did it
so
at the end of every art project it's
nice to go around and give some
compliments to each other so let's go
around and see what each other has done
because i'm i'm burning with curiosity
to see what sam has put together what
matt what random put together i'm
curious to see what you put together
nico nico asset lord perringer
look the bar for this one for me is
sky high i know that nico has been
downloading gigabytes of assets for this
so i don't know what he's got in store
for us but it's probably gonna look
pretty sweet
oh wow
weird oh i love the red that hdri is
amazing you nailed the like tree layer
look like how like the trees are like
real high up close and kind of swoop
down a little bit i like how you also
added a light inside of the cabin i
stole that from you
i picked up my shoulder my working
shoulder and looked around it was a
happy little thing
i love the color contrast i love the the
gradient of colors you have you have the
blue red yellow green love your flowers
right here that's great thank you man
and those are some good assets you got
there i might have to
speak to you about those later well i
think uh let's just go right down the
line yeah yeah any uh any artistic
statements you want to make um i had a
lot of technical difficulties so i just
tried to adapt so i just put my own
little spin on it i hope you guys enjoy
it
[Music]
oh wow look at that hey that looks
really great
that looks really good that does look
great that sun in the background is
actually like perfect so the thing that
stands out to me is that you like
everything feels like coherent in terms
of where it's placed there's a lot of
fidelity to it too it's like really
crispy thanks guys
you're welcome that's pretty sweet so i
figured i wasn't gonna be able to make
something as photorealistic as what you
guys did so i went the other
[Music]
direction oh wow that's amazing though
that's very cute that's super sick that
little like freaking ding-dong house
like what is that it looks like a little
church
it's cute i was i was trying to do a
bunch of like subsurface scattering
materials i bought a really cool pack
from this guy called new plastic on
youtube oh i see yeah that really helps
make the tree look a little more like
tree-like anyway i wanted to add haze
but i realized i didn't have enough time
to figure out how to get the haze to
work here so instead i just pumped that
bloom
it works it works
how did you do the path the path is
literally just a plane i made in the
final 30 seconds and i just like squish
it into place and put
it fits perfectly yeah it looks great
the path honestly brings it all together
i'm very surprised i'm legitimately
impressed i'm pretty pleased with it i
wish there i wish i could add a lot more
stuff to it i feel like i was able to
really channel the vibe of that
environment
when you see this you're going to feel
like you can step right into that
environment
make you want to take your shoe off and
run through the
run through there with naked foots
[Music]
oh
that looks really good why don't we just
hit this button
wait what we can live inside you made a
bob ross video game
so there you go
feel free to take a take a deeper look
into this world i created look at these
trees sam's got the right type of trees
we got the broad leaves versus the pine
needles oh and the forest just keeps
going that's really incredible honestly
that's like legit incredible i'm really
impressed honestly you guys freaking
knocked it out of the park i was
really legitimately worried that we were
gonna like set ourselves up for failure
by trying to do it in a bob ross like 27
minutes
like that's not a lot of time seriously
though this is pretty chill landscapes
3d rendering landscapes is the most
chill thing i was pretty stressed out
you know the real question of who won is
going to be answered on instagram so
we're all going to make an export here
for images and go up on instagram in a
poll will be anonymous
and we'll see who gets picked
when it comes to creativity there are no
winners or losers or that's what they
say so we decided to put our pictures on
instagram and see if they're actually
our winners or losers and over there
they're fighting over them
[Laughter]
the poll 35 000 people voted the winner
by a landslide
damn the
unreal buy a landslide it all paid off
now i don't look like an [ __ ]
i don't look arrogant i was pretty chill
because i knew before it started i had
this one in the bag
[Music]
[Laughter]
sam was the secret sauce unreal or was
the secret sauce you ah it's me because
i i learned how to use unreal
it's like i've done this in like
traditional programs before and i've
just known that like when we're
following along with a person who's
literally painting the image right there
in front of you you need something
that's like insanely fast also too i
just want to say i think i had the most
bob ross points i was helping everybody
out
okay so that was the first time i ever
used octane scanner i was like i don't
know what to do matt help we're gonna
where can we see some more your 3d work
uh you can see on instagram matt
underscore column
uh what does the winner get
the right to wear a blue shirt
that was our bob ross olympics and you
just
claimed the title you did that
you sam you
you know what i really like
people that leave comments you know why
because the people that left comments on
the instagram feed declared me the
winner but you know what the only way
we're gonna settle this score is to do
another vfx challenge so please leave a
comment down below as to what you think
we should do for our next vfx challenge
thank you